when AMD released their navi 5500 xt
about a month ago my initial impressions
were meh
this was a card that was coming in with
really not a whole lot extra for the
three years in the making over the
predecessors the RX v 7t + RX 580
additions which weren't that impressive
over the 470 and 480 to be honest though
fast forward a month drivers and also
prices which is a big subject of today's
video have had a bit of time to mature
and we've also got some extra models in
today's comparison we've got the
sapphire pulse 4 gigabyte and also the
Zeus a gigabyte ROG Strix and the
gigabyte 5500 XT 8 gigabyte OC Edition
which when we look at it looks like
they've used the exact same cooler as
the 1660 supe though let's roll those
gaming benchmarks for you guys and we're
going to also include the RX 590 finally
we're in the last comparison I did
actually didn't have the rx 590 on hand
do do a lot of miscommunication mishap
[Music]
[Laughter]
so what you can see from those 1080p and
1440p benchmarks was some really
surprising numbers and that is basically
if you're in the market for one of these
cards you'll definitely want to get the
8 gigabyte edition at least the games
that are coming out with higher textures
and they demand more vram as shadows of
the Tomb Raider really showed the
difference of what can happen when you
don't have enough vram to the point
where the rx 584 gigabyte was actually
beating out the 5500 XT 4 gigabyte some
other games also showed this trend
happening though overall the 4 gigabyte
model was very close to the 8 gigabyte
model when you didn't come into any vram
bottlenecks though what was more
surprising and a little bit
disheartening for me was that the RX 590
was basically neck and neck with the
5500 XT and sometimes beating it out in
different benchmarks even though the
power consumption was substantially
lower on the 5500 XT a lot of gamers do
want to get value for money at the face
value of those cards so an RX 590 coming
in at pretty much the same price and
being out for quite a while doesn't
really give the 5500 XT the value
proposition that a lot of gamers were
hoping for and I wholeheartedly agree
with all the upstanding tech US citizens
out there where in the previous video
you guys said that the MSRP is on these
5500 XD 4G by making you buy models
really need to come down about 20
dollars to make this card more of a
compelling option and after speaking
with a few retailers there is actually
another scary curveball to throw in in
relation to the pricing but we will talk
about that later let's go over the three
models that we have here on the desk
that were introduced into the
benchmarking this time around and what
we can see is that the Zeus ROG Strix
and the gigabyte OC for what it's worth
these cards are performing pretty much
identical in the numbers and the good
thing is about all three of these cards
here on the bench is that their power
consumption is in line it's looking
really good
where I've actually redone all the power
consumption figures now where I'm pretty
much focusing on just stressing out the
GPU as opposed to doing other benchmarks
in games sometimes when those numbers
are higher on that GPU for instance if
it's a more powerful GPU
that will then stress the CPU more
essentially inflating the power
consumption numbers so this test with
the max msaa
does tend to put a lot more of a strain
on the GPU as opposed to the CPU but
what we can see in those power
consumption numbers is that the seven
nanometer and also the Navi architecture
is giving us a big power efficiency
boost another good thing on top of that
is that all these three cards out of the
box have exceptionally low noise as well
as really good temperatures the rog
Strix did excel in having the lowest GPU
core temp but the memory and vrm
temperatures really averaged out to be
very similar across all three cards
there's also on the ROG Strix the option
to have RGB which also has an LED button
which you can press to turn off the very
small amount of RGB where it's just
essentially a small ROG logo there's
also right beside that a bios switch
where you can change it with dual BIOS
into quiet mode now I didn't test the
quiet mode because the performance mode
I thought was already ridiculously quiet
and the performance numbers were quite
good as well as the temperatures they're
looking at these cards the ROG has a
massive one kilogram cooler the gigabyte
has about 700 grams and the Sapphire
pulse is just a little bit lighter than
that the Sapphire pulse however has two
100ml fans just like the ROG Strix
however it is a shorter card and they've
done an exceptional job of making the
most out of this design thinking about
AC did have 80 ml fans but it does have
three of those versus the two on the
other models but that did give it
essentially a little bit more noise over
the other two on the back of all three
cards you've also got three DisplayPort
outs as well as an HDMI 2.0 out though
the ROG Strix and also the sapphire
pulse incorporate metal back plates as
opposed to the gigabyte which has a
plastic backplate which pretty much just
for aesthetic purposes on top of that
all three models require an eight pin PC
power connector they're basically
breaking these cards down for you guys
if you were to go out and buy any one of
these models you wouldn't be making a
bad decision over picking one over the
other and that they all had good
performance and they did so with
relatively low noise however there is a
focus out there at the moment with the
5700 XT ROG cards as well as the tough
series where a colleague of mine Steve
from harbor unbox has reviewed both the
xtr OG Strix model and the 5700 tough
and he thought they were very lackluster
where they had some inherent problems of
their own
with the 5500 XT I haven't incurred any
problems whatsoever it's a really solid
card so if you were to buy this model
you wouldn't be suffering the same
issues as those other two cards have but
now comes that question ultimately of
are these cards are goodbye and as I
said in the intro my initial impressions
were met with the 5500 XT and coming out
of this review today my impressions are
still really met to the point where
they're even more met because of the
street pricing of these cards which
we're going to go a little bit more in
depth where the ROG Strix for example is
coming in at 230 USD on Amazon and also
the gigabyte o C's coming in at 210
that's a substantial amount higher than
the MSRP prices that AMD promised which
I feel were already pretty expensive for
this class of GPU and especially since
they're now on seven nanometer
they've also got access to a small
silicon guy area then the RX 590 and RX
580 and so I guess a lot of gamers are
disappointed in the price performance of
the 5500 XT and the board partners have
done an excellent job in implementing
these cards here you see on the desk but
unfortunately when the base that they've
got to work with isn't that good and
you've already got something like the
1660s super out there then that's a
really hard sell for AMD with these
cards and now here's where things get
even more complicated for the 5500 XT
and that is when I spoke to retailers
they're pretty much scared to order
these cards in mass quantities because
the demand really isn't there and when
they're not ordering in mass quantities
then they're not getting access to
cheaper prices inherently so take for
instance the 1660s super I recently
picked these up in Australia for 290
hacia pop the Sapphire here comes in at
$300 ozzie for the 4 gigabyte model so
in Australia I'm saving $10 to go with a
1660 Super which has more V RAM and has
much better performance figures not to
mention it's also got a better onboard
encoder than the 5500 X
he does and the power efficiency of the
1660s super is also really good
now the 1650s super actually had one of
those but I sold them in a build so it's
not in today's comparison but that is
falling into a similar category as the
5500 XT it's just not offering really
any compelling value where in my
previous video I had the recommendation
of if you were getting into gaming
around this price segment I would
honestly just save your money go out and
buy an RX 570 or step it up to a 1660
super and that's pretty much exactly
where my recommendation is still
standing after testing these cards out
here sure they do a decent job of
playing games but they're not offering
anything to be wowed about especially in
this price segment does that being said
we got the 5600 XT right around the
corner so stay tuned for that that is in
a higher price segment with the MSRP
coming in at 279 dollars though what
will that bring to the table will that
be the card to step things up from the
1660 super make sure you stay tuned for
that review coming in the next few days
but as it stands 5500 XT I can't help
but be met by this card and definitely a
lot of people out there would say that
they're disappointed with the 5500 XT
I'm just somewhere in the middle and the
reason being is because if you went out
and bought one of these cards like I
said before you're still going to be
playing games absolutely fine
essentially you didn't get hosed there
was only really one car that struck out
to me as a really bad Buy in the last
few years and that was the GT 1030 ddr4
Edition where they got nerfed and that
was an extremely bad Buy
that being said none of these cards here
are an extremely bad Buy and so that's
where my recommendation just stands at
and with all that aside I hope you guys
enjoyed today's review if you did then
be sure to hit that like button for us
and also let us know in the comment
section below which of these three
models is your favorite out of the bunch
and also we've talked about that
compounded problem with the demand from
actual retails in that if they're
demanding more cards then they're going
to be able to pass those prices on and
that compound of problem that exists for
the 5500 XT as opposed to the 5700 and
also the 5700 XT where those cards are
much more in demand because I feel like
them
more competitive in their price point so
do let us know also what you think about
that compound of problem love reading
your thoughts and opinions as always and
speaking of thoughts and opinions we
have the question of the day which comes
from Chris H and they asked what about
your office pcs how do you market those
and sell those today is it harder to
sell those than gaming PC's and who's
your customer base in age mostly for
office pcs I love this question and
basically the office PC I've done a
video on that I'll put the link up here
where the whole purpose of this is to
basically flip your components that
aren't intended for gaming for instance
if we got a third gen HP system that
wouldn't support any decent graphics
card we could then take the i7 out of
that if it had an i7 take all the 16
gigabytes of RAM out and then use that
on another motherboard and then a since
we've got a motherboard which should be
slapping i3 in cheap hard drive and then
bang it out as an office PC and we would
still be getting some return on our
money rather than just chucking that out
which I know some people just do Chuck
that stuff out and as you guys have
pointed out I am a big advocate on
recycling old hardware but as for the
last part of that question the age group
who buys office pcs is generally like
around 30 to 40 years old people who
have businesses and they just need a
really cheap PC to open up Excel
spreadsheets and just do something
essentially what an office PC would do
and they get it a really cheap price and
that's all they're getting it for so
they're getting good value for money
because I only essentially priced the
parts out of what I paid for them in
relation to a provided rate out of those
builds so I'm essentially getting my
money back instead of chucking it out
and usually the age group is both men
and women who are just looking for a
cheap office PC you usually never get
young people coming in and buying them
there's usually older people who run a
business and have no interest in gaming
whatsoever and I hope that answers that
question and I'll catch you guys in
another tech video very soon if you've
enjoyed this one and you've stayed this
barn you're not yet subbed and you're
enjoying the content be sure to hit that
sub button ring the bell to get the
content as soon as it drops here at Tech
yes City and I'll see you in the next
Tech video very soon peace out for now
bye
[Music]